Let's kick off things with some food news.
Okay, too late.
All we do is talk about food.
It's true by the way.
Well, they just held the annual CES,
which is the Consumer Electronic Show
and brands show off all their latest high tech products.
This is like Disneyland for gadgets.
Uh huh.
And I saw something Ross and I had to show you.
Okay, cause I want it real bad.
It's an ice cream robot.
No!
Yes, CNET reports, that ColdSnap
is gonna make a soft serve on demand.
Basically, Keurig coffee pods, but with ice cream.
2020 was a hard year,
2021 coming through with an ice cream robot.
Thank you so much.
I love soft serve.
I used to work at McDonald's
and I would do a register, drive-through,
and grill the triple threat.
And I would do the soft serve cone thing
and I can do the whole thing
with a little (tongue click) at the top.
Like the little like, like.
Perfect little hook.
All I know is McDonald's you're a miracle,
everybody knows it.
But that ice cream you make
is my favorite ice cream in the world
with the hot fudge and some nuts, oh my God.
Uh huh, I know the half and half, the swirl.
Anyone else in the mood for some sweets right now?
Yes!
Well here's some good news, it's Girl Scout cookie season.
(crowd cheers)
I know, just when you thought you wanted soft serve,
JK, I want Girl Scout cookies.
Food and Wine reports that the girl Scouts
moved their entire operation online.
Remember they used to sit outside the store.
Of course.
I know, I'd always feel bad
cause I'd never buy any.
I'm always on a diet.
Well, you can order on their website now
through their partnership with Grub Hub.
Okay, and welcome to the future, so easy.
Plus, they've got a brand new cookie
inspired by french toast called Toast Yay.
I like the thin mints.
Do you do those ones?
I like the thin mints and to put them in the freezer.
I'm that guy.
Yeah, I eat so many of them,
I call them double chin mints.
(crowd laughs)
First of all, why only now?
This should have been happening
since like the birth of www.HelpMeGetMeSomeGirlScoutCookies.
I know it's so much smarter,
you can just order them online.
I do buy them though,
when I see them on the streets, I do.
I always pony up and then.
Yeah, I always have a conversation.
I go, I'd love to support you, but do you see my body?
This doesn't happen if I'm eating cookies, sorry.
Well, another thing that I really love doing Ross,
is puzzles, big puzzler.
Uh huh, I just started.
I told you I did my first one in quarantine.
It gave me such anxiety, but now I'm obsessed with them.
I won't do a puzzle if the box is opened.
Why?
Because if I do all that work
and then there's like a missing piece at the end
it's going to send me into an insane asylum.
(Ross laughs)
I'm so close to being there already.
I shan't get that one piece,
to send me to over the edge.
But they're so fun and they are so satisfying.
You can get that last piece in there.
Well, it's great to do alone or with other people.
It's like, it's perfect game.
You know, whether you're alone or with friends.
And I'm so happy
that people are puzzling more than ever right now.
And despite the renewed puzzle passion
there are still some pieces missing in the puzzle industry.
Mm hmm.
And that's where Puzzles Of Color comes in.
It's a small business started
by a brother and a sister duet, from Allen, Texas,
who wanted to bring better representation to puzzles.
And guess what?
What?
They're here!
No.
(crowd cheers)
Please welcome, William Jones and Erica Chambers!
Hi guys!
Hey.
Hi!
Hi.
Oh my gosh, hi.
Our missing puzzle pieces, right here.
Yeah thank you.
Hi.
Erica and William, I love your puzzles.
I love what they stand for.
I love how they look.
What inspired you to get on and do this?
It's hard to build a business.
We actually grew up doing puzzles as really young kids.
We started doing them in elementary school
as a winter break thing.
My mom wanted to keep our minds fresh.
She wanted to make sure that, you know,
we were entertained during
that week and a half off in between the New Year.
And so as we, you know
we're older and we were trying to find more and more
challenging puzzles.
We realized that we really weren't seeing anything
that featured people of color.
And that was, you know
there wasn't a lot of diversity in the industry.
So we decided we'd try to see if we could change that.
That's so cool, I love that,
that there's such a purpose behind it.
I also love that footage too.
Watching how they cut the puzzles.
I didn't know that's how you did it.
That's do neat!
I also wonder how you pick your images.
See there we're looking at the footage
of how they cut it.
Yup.
And so the puzzles flipped upside down
and when you flip it up, you can see how beautiful.
How do you pick the pictures,
like that one right there?
Who makes that, does the art?
We find artists of color.
More likely social media
and like, really like talking to the artists,
getting their backstory
and getting the story behind the actual puzzle itself.
To really like, you know,
we want to make sure we're telling a diverse story.
Or telling a story of anybody can relate to or anything.
Anybody who sees this would be like,
yeah, that's great a great puzzle.
I need to have that in my house as art.
That's great, and you have done,
you've done like eight puzzles all out of Erica's garage.
What's next?
Yeah, so far.
Then you're taking over the world.
So what do you do next with the business?
We really love our artists
and so we're trying to highlight them
in the best way possible.
So we're doing a little video series with our artists
and of course always looking for more and more art.
Well, we'd love to feature you on the website
and continue to talk about you guys
and shine a light on the important
and beautiful thing you are doing
and hearing as a parent that your mom
encouraged you to do puzzles growing up.
Like I'm the bigger puzzler and I don't have my kids do it.
And I feel like I've learned a lesson today,
that I need to get my kids involved more.
Yeah, absolutely, it's a great time to bond.
Like that's how we are, you know, we're really, really close
because I think a lot, and in part,
because of doing puzzles together for so many years.
I'm worried I'd take them too seriously
to let my children get involved.
Me too.
I could see that.
Yeah.
We definitely, we did have a situation
when we were younger where one of our cousins
was helping and lost some puzzle pieces.
Oh my gosh.
Oh no.
And it was, it was disaster.
Yeah, well, I'm that guy.
Who's like, you take it seriously.
So go to our website at the DrewBarrymoreShow.com
where we're going to feature all these puzzles,
how to send an art, where to buy it.
Erica and William, thank you so much,
for being on our show
and help illuminating this gorgeous business
of PuzzlesOfColor.com.
And thank you for being on the show today.
(upbeat music)